everyone knows video games are the best
but we should acknowledge that sometimes
they're frustrating these are the 50
most frustrating moments in video games
thinking you're done with a maze but
then realizing you missed adopt falling
point two seconds short of getting your
s license this jump which is the hardest
in the game missions where you pilot an
RC helicopter memorizing the fatality
practising the fatality beating your
friend and messing up the fatality
beating a level just two birds and for
some reason the game only gives you two
stars when you just can't get a line
piece insta kill lasers that go mmmmmm
spending hours reading a golden chocobo
and realizing you just spend hours
breeding chocobos what's worse even
three the Elite Four losing to the
fourth and having to start the whole
thing over or when you walk into a cave
and there's a million Hawking Zubin
protecting the toy while she's hacking
getting knocked out by Mike Tyson's yes
drop in a combo and Tony Hawk failing
during that last solo and green grass
and high tides a song that by the way is
10 minutes long turret levels current
levels some jerk camping the spawn point
getting stuck on a puzzle giving up
looking up the solution on YouTube and
then realizing that the tutorial is
hosted by a 9 year old being the new guy
on a server full of people have been
playing for years putting a quarter into
an old game and only then remembering
that pretty much all old games are
impossible winning rainbowroad only to
get new shelled into oblivion
trying to beat Wiz vic trying to get a
Nintendo game working games designed to
be frustrating it doesn't make them less
frustrating the I just can't wait to be
king level don't laugh it's impossible
basically every puzzle in every
adventure game but especially this
desert game racking bugs not being able
to get a Riddler trophy that's behind a
fence even though oh I don't know you're
Batman any level with these medusa heads
this barrel and carnival night zone
whatever the music sped up because you
were running out of air in underwater
level this underwater level all
underwater levels all levels where you
have to escort someone tripping on a
staircase and turning yourself in a
stone just trust me on this one when
you're playing something multiplayer
online your family around whoever calls
and you can't pause the game when a
brand new PC game won't work on your
brand-new PC having to climb a ladder in
a first-person shooter
trippy dream sequences when your friend
has full health and you have no health
and he eats the turkey anyway this dogs
laugh games have don't have passwords
your save system saving your game the
moment before something stupid you can't
avoid happens accidentally hitting no
Nintendo game when a character asks you
understood all that the water temple
when you get a new game and you can't
even figure out the first thing you're
supposed to do the turbo tunnel what you
think I forgot it the great maze this
Genesis game met at one point requires
you fizz
we get up and reset the system in order
to proceed yes this is a real idea
someone once had with absolute most
frustrating part in all of videogames is
when you're trying to get to the next
level or in life jet pack or whatever it
is it when you realize that there isn't
enough time for all of the videogames
that you want to play I'm just kidding
let's play video games all the time